So I was a scrum... what was it called?
Like a scrum master?
No, scrum breaker.
Scrum breaker.
So I went in and like, we should do this and like the whole scrum team is like, we hate you.
So I was scrum breaker.
What's up, everybody? This is TechnoGeek from the CTPB pod.
So we have a really exciting feature that we are going to be rolling out at the drop of this episode.
It is our Discord community.
So we are going to be emphasizing a lot of really cool, exciting, exclusive features within the Discord community.
We'd love to interact with the people who listen to our pod and love our pod.
If you want to chat with other hackers, you want to discuss bugs.
You know, we're hoping to have the guests in there as well, although I don't know if they will answer questions.
So just, you know, don't ping them and stuff.
But, you know, we're hoping to have a lot of really awesome people in there to just come and hang out and build an awesome community.
So if that sounds like something that's interesting to you, you can go to ctbb.show slash discord and that will take you right to the Discord server join invite link.
We will also be rolling out a couple paid premium tiers.
So if you want to financially help support the pod, that would be amazing.
It would help pay our editors.
It would help us make better content for you.
And yeah, that's going to have some exclusive stuff that comes with it, like AMAs and masterclass sessions and some exclusive, you know, we're going to show some unredacted bugs, stuff like that.
So if that sounds like something that's interesting to you, let us know and, you know, come join our Discord community.
Again, that's ctbb.show slash discord and you can join the community.
Hoping to see you there.
Peace.
All right, dude, Franz, we're rolling.
Welcome to the podcast, man.
Thank you so much.
Thanks for inviting me.
Of course.
And so actually, before we jump into this episode, I've got to highlight what the heck this thing is behind you.
Yeah.
There's like a, it looks like it's like a framed poster of you with a shell on Google.
Is that exactly what that is?
Yeah, it is.
It's from 2014, I think.
2014?
Are you kidding me?
Holy crap.
No.
Yeah, yeah.
14.
Yeah.
Were you born then?
Dude, shut up.
I was, I, that's the year I graduated high school, actually.
Yeah.
That's, I think it was from an XXE if I recall correctly.
Wow, dude, that's nuts.
So he's just got like Etsy password on from a Google box on the wall behind him.
That's pretty freaking neat.
That's amazing.
All right, guys.
So as, as we often do, when we start off the critical thinking podcast, I'm going to have to go into Justin's storytime a little bit.
Okay.
So Justin's storytime is this.
I, I was at my, the setting was this.
Justin was a new, a new bug bounty hunter.
And I had just weaseled my way into my first live hacking event.
Okay.
Um, and I had, I had, I was very nervous.
I was the plus one of a plus one.
And, uh, it was amazing to get to see all of these hackers that I, um, you know, had respected for so long.
Uh, but there was one guy in particular, you may be able to guess who that I had not gone and talked to you because I was just too nervous.
I was too nervous, man.
I was like, there's no way I can go up and talk to Franz or isn't.
And I was talking to my wife, Mariah, and I was like, listen, Franz is like a legend.
Like I can't, I can't go up and talk to him.
And she's like, Justin, you're at this live hacking event.
You have to go up and talk to him.
And at that event, you had found a crazy bug, um, with, with, uh, you know, an S3 bucket, you know, pulling stuff in and stuff like that.
Um, and so I went up and talked to you and you were so kind to explain the whole bug to me and just chat.
And that was my, my first, you know, fanboy moment where I was like, wait a second, Franz is a real human.
What's up with that?
So, yeah.
Wow.
Oh, that's amazing.
That's an awesome start.
You know, normally they say, don't meet your heroes, but I must say, Franz, you did not disappoint.
So that's awesome.
That's awesome.
Yeah.
So there's your little, there's your little flattering intro.
Um, for those of you that don't know Franz, um, Franz is a legend, a hacker,
a, uh, a bug bounty OG.
Um, and dude, I'm looking at this, this, this plan that we have for this episode and it's so long.
I'm not even sure we're going to be able to get through all of this because there's just so much good content that you've put out.
Um, so thank you for that.
But before we get into all that, let's go ahead and talk about how you got into bug bounty in the first place, because you, you got in when it was really early on the scene and give us a little career walkthrough that brought you to the point where you could do bug bounty.
Sure.
I think, I mean, initially everything started off as hiring two young people, uh, to my company as developers.
And these two young guys, uh, Matthias Carlson and Fredrik Anroth, uh, they were lurking always inside in the corner in the office doing stuff together always.
And, and you, you didn't figure it like, you couldn't really understand what they were doing, but, but when you started talking with them, you realize like they were probably like art spoofing the whole office.
Oh my gosh.
That's hilarious.
Laughing.
I'm going to pause you really quickly there.
So you, you were, you at this point you were already an entrepreneur.
So you started, you had already started your company.
Yeah.
So I can start when, when I was born.
No, no, no.
So I, yeah, exactly.
Take us back.
No.
So I, I started as a developer like super early on.
And then, uh, I, I built the company together with, uh, with a business partner of mine and we hired a Frederick and Matthias.
And at that time I, I wasn't into hacking.
I, I knew that like sanitize your inputs.
That was, that was basically the, the, the idea that I, that I knew was, was something in, in regards to security.
Uh, but this was very timed also because like this was 2000 and I think 10 or 11 or something.
And, and, uh, I, I got curious on what they were doing.
And at some point they told us that they were planning on building like a company security, like a security company, automating security issues.
So we were pretty interested in that.
And we started talking more deep around, like, what would you do?
What, like, what is the product?
And we kind of realized, uh, early on that we could do this together, especially because we saw a need for it in terms of what we were building.
We were building like e-commerce websites and, and CMS websites and stuff.
So we, we then created the tech defy.
Hmm.
And, uh, and at that point, just when we got started, the bug bounty scene, uh, basically was initiated.
Uh, so it started with like Mozilla and I think it was PayPal and Google.
And I think Facebook was early on as well.
And then you had, you had like, like Russian things as well.
And, and some, uh, what, what was it?
There was something else also that was like super early on.
I think eBay was early on as well.
Like there was a few of those that, that started, uh, and, and you, you basically had like a, a way to do like research on a huge amount of surface.
Like you could test a bunch of things on, on this attack surface.
And so that was very helpful in like getting to understand what they were looking for, but because now you didn't have to like hide or simulate fake things.
You could literally like focus on, on looking for real bugs.
So that got me curious on like, what should I start with?
And I think they, they basically showed me a bunch of XSS things and, and that that's where I like started off.
And, uh, and played like XSS was my, you know, where I was born and then, and then it grew from there.
Uh, so I think that was, I think it was very helpful for me to have people next to me that I could ask.
And also to, to, you know, whenever I didn't know anything, I could just ask them and then I could play myself and then I could come back and like get that feedback.
This is so awesome because you, you, you, you, you were in a position of, you know, owning this company or whatever, and you hire Matias.
I didn't know that that was actually how you, you met Matias in the first place.
And then you're willing, you know, you're willing and engaged at a level where, you know, you can say like, Hey, what are you doing?
And then you start this company with them and it just shows this really, you know, learner mentality.
And Matias is like, you know, Matias is young at this point. Right?
Yeah. Yeah. I think they were, they were drop offs from, from the university.
I think there was like, there were like 18 or 19. No way.
If even that. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Absolutely. And, and they, they came basically in and, and like, they were, they were okay developers, but they were much better when it comes to like security.
And, and security related things. That's when, when they were like shiny in terms of skills.
Yeah. So we felt that like, it's much better for you to like focus on those things than, you know, making an integration with an invoice provider.
Like, please stop writing code. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. No, not really. Like write other code that is like much more fun to run.
No, that's, that's wrong. I, I, I've been meaning to get Matias on the pod as well.
So I think I'm going to send him a message right after this episode, because I'd love to hear his origin story as well.
And his side of this situation where he's like, so there's this guy and he hired me onto this company.
And then he's like, why are you ARP spoofing the whole office? You know?
I love that. He's like, he had probably has a totally different story. He's like, no, I wasn't hired. I just came into this company.
I just showed up one day. I didn't get paid. Yeah. Right. Right. Exactly.
Okay. So that's really interesting to, to hear that, that, that like shift.
So you were basically just doing entirely like software development. When you learned about like the security side of it, what sort of piqued your interest to like make that pivot that like really drew you towards security?
Cause I imagine like if you're doing a lot of software development stuff, you probably could have just kept doing that and not made, made a switch into security.
So what, what was that like draw? I think, I think so I've been like, I was building, you know, systems like you, you, you say you're building a system, but like, what is the system in, in, in reality?
But I was always like, as a developer, I always try to like, Oh, I can reuse this. I need to build this like modular and, and all these things.
So I was always curious on how others were doing it. And this was like, I've realized this probably now after like 14 years, but I, I've kind of know that like through the whole time, but like, I'm super curious on how other people thought about problems and issues.
And I, I've always like, I've almost made it a challenge to myself to write like pseudo code of how something is implemented.
So I can make a black box, a white box.
Right. Right.
Right. Just because that's the way I understand how they thought about things. And also that's how you find that specific little if statement that they forgot about.
Sure. Sure. And I think, I think that was, that was the point where I realized that I could do this on other companies and nobody will like get me into trouble.
And I can just, you know, start poking at them and see what's what, what will happen.
And I think that was, that was something that I'd like, I can do this and also get paid.
Like this was something I was poking at before, you know, just figuring out how stuff worked.
Um, and now I could do it, help other companies and also, you know, get paid for it.
Yeah. So I think that was, that was the trigger to like, okay, I can actually gain knowledge by doing this.
And also I have like a side effect of, I can actually, you know, make, make money for it.
Yeah, absolutely. And, and I think, go ahead.
No, no, no. And I think what, what happened in the beginning also, when we started with the bug bounty was like those, those money came in to our company.
So we could fund, you know, this company, like start these other companies.
So it kind of, it, it, it was like a very, like a beautiful environment of like, we get to poke on other companies and that creates other companies.
And it was like, it was a very nice, you know, circling effect of, of, of hunting for bugs.
Yeah. And.
Yeah. And you see this a lot with, with bug bounty origin companies, right?
Like in the beginning, when you're trying to like make ends meet and stuff like that, you can even use bug bounty to fund your own company, right?
As income into the company. So I think that provides a really nice launching place for, um, you know, bug bounty hunters to, uh, become entrepreneurs in that context.
For sure. There are, there are many that, that has like popped up.
Yeah. Yeah. And I've gotten, I've, I actually was just speaking to another one this morning who we'll have on the pod.
So there's definitely some, that's one of the things I'm really interested in is bug bounty plus entrepreneurship.
So we'll definitely cover more of that later. And I've actually got a section on this doc.
If we get through all of it to pick your brain a little bit more about that.
Um, but I think you said a really interesting thing relating to how you think about hacking, which was that you try to write pseudocode so that you can kind of understand what you're going to do.
So that you can kind of understand how the developers, you know, would have, would have written this code and turn it, you know, from a black box into a white box.
Um, and I've, I kind of saw this when we were collaborating at the last life hacking event we were at.
Um, and, and you can get like small indicators and that like this indicator confirms that they've done something like this, because if this doesn't happen, then, and, and it turns almost into a, like a game where you can like, I'm going to guess what happens if I do this.
I'm going to get an error and then like, yes, I'm getting an error.
Then I know that they've done this and that.
Yeah, exactly.
Like, yeah, that that's, that's, and I think that's probably one of the things that makes you such a good, uh, exploit exploit exploiter.
Exploitation.
Yeah.
You know, like, I don't know the actual word, but, um, you know, someone who's really able to take an issue and just poke, poke, poke, poke, poke, poke, poke, poke until you turn it into a crazy vulnerability.
Um, so that's, that's definitely a cool tip for anybody who has that sort of developer like brain to kind of, you know, really be intentional about theorizing.
Cause I think to some degree, we're all doing this a little bit when we're hacking.
Absolutely.
But I think if you take that extra step and really start thinking in the forefront of your brain, Hey, how did they write this?
How is this, how can I confirm this?
You know, what little errors might tell me whether it's this or that, um, you, you can flesh it out a lot more.
And it's the same thing.
Like when, when you've done it with one place and they have done, you know, a similar thing somewhere else.
Yeah.
Then you can like start comparing them and like, okay, but it behaves differently there.
Like you can, so as soon as you've done that for like one code block, you can see other implementations in the same company.
If they've done like, you've done a mistake on one, like that, that happens a lot.
Like there's one single thing that, that makes everything break.
Yeah.
No, no, absolutely.
I mean, there's almost like two different buckets of, of this type of stuff when you're doing testing where, um, like the cat just, he's part of the show too.
Um, yeah, but there's almost like two buckets where like, uh, you, you can, there's like lots of like almost totally like out of left field type of stuff where you'll test.
You'll be like, maybe they did this, maybe they did that.
Like, you never know.
Maybe, maybe they made this weird mistake.
Like I saw this somewhere else.
And then there's the very like logical approach where you think about it.
So sort of basically as if you're one of the developers or you're coming from the developer's perspective, which is, you know, you know, some of the technologies that they're using, you know, some of the common mistakes that happen within those languages and those technologies.
And so you can sort of piece things together.
You can try things that are a little more targeted towards like, say you're testing, you know, a Java application.
Absolutely.
You're going to test stuff that's similar to spring or, you know, you're going to be testing for like Java specific things instead of like Ruby issues or JavaScript issues.
Yeah.
And that type of testing, like, it's not to say that if you test a Ruby issue on a Java stack that like maybe there's something further down the line that might pop.
And, you know, but oftentimes having that context as like a developer is really, really useful because you absolutely have that like that background of like, oh, I would say this is something weird that they might have done.
Yeah. And I would say one, one of the things you're mentioning there is like, like, I don't know why I think people are talking about it in a different context, but like typing is like one of the most, one of the best things and one of the worst things in combination that you can use.
Like, that's one of our biggest tools that we have is, is when, like, for example, when you have PHP, you don't have typing.
So that's where, what you have there is like, then you can start figuring out where they screwed up and thought it was an int, but it's a string.
And, and in other languages, it's like, just because you have the typing errors, you can start fussing, you know, variables that didn't exist because you're getting a typing error.
And so like, when you think about it, like that's, that's one of my best clues that there's, you know, that I can hunt for things.
It's like typing issues or typing errors, basically.
Yeah, absolutely. And I feel like that's a really good transition into one of the tools that you wrote.
I don't know. When was this like 2017 or something?
This like this S3 decloaking tool.
Oh yeah.
This bucket disclosure tool.
Yeah. Do you want to like talk about that a little bit?
Cause there's, you did a whole blog post and stuff, but I feel like, yeah, I've got you.
Yeah. The blog post is, is so what happened with that blog post was like, I had fun bugs that I wanted to explain, but then I realized, okay, I need to take one step back.
Like, do people know what this is? And like, do people know why this bug happens? And do people know what S3 is? And then like, do people know what the internet is? And like that, that the blog post just grew up.
No.
Did I lose you?
Yeah.
I saw that.
Yeah. So it's looking right now. It says you're 1% uploaded. Do you have any?
Yeah, I see 1% uploading.
Do you have, so normally.
It goes from one to zero always.
Yeah. So, so do you have a way to like make your internet stronger? Like, are you etherneted in right now? Or are you?
I can, I can try. I wonder what I have for, what I have on my phone instead, because it's weird because it says, oh, wow. Maybe. Could I have been the stupid person in the room?
What did you, what did you do?
I don't want to say.
He's got proxy on right now.
I turn it off.
I think it works at 9% uploaded. That was definitely it. All right. So, all right.
It goes to S3.
What do you think it goes to S3?
Wait, wait, wait. I need to check my, my. Oh, fuck. Yeah. Sorry. It was my mistake.
Yeah. So yeah, everything went through Burt, man.
Dude, that's hilarious. Okay. So, so we've been dealing with some issues with Franz cutting in and out for this past, like 20 minutes.
And you know what it was? He left freaking Burt proxy on.
So, classic hacker mistake here.
Yeah.
So I'm not sure, really sure where, where it cut out, but we'll, we'll bring it back around.
Rest in peace, Burt state.
Yeah. Dude, your Burt file just blew up.
But yeah. Okay. So, you know, you talked a little bit about, about, you know, the testing methodology where you're, you're thinking about, you know, the code structures, you're thinking about things like variable typing.
First, and I will say, you know, when you said typing for the first time, I was like, yeah, man, you know, everybody types when they're hacking.
Oh, okay. Yeah.
What the heck are you talking about? Typing is one of our greatest tools.
I also thought you were talking about typing as well.
Oh my gosh. That's really funny.
But, so I guess I wanted to dive a little bit into that.
So we've seen the side already we've, or at least we've talked a little bit about the side of like, exploitationist fronds.
You know, once you see a weird issue, you, you poke at it, you model out the code, you know, you're thinking about how the developer would have implemented it.
And you're thinking about how you can validate those assumptions by triggering different edge cases throughout, throughout the code base.
Yeah.
I'm curious about fleshing a little bit more out about your, your hacker methodology, because one of the things we've seen in the past with hackers that have come on here is that you, you have a couple extremes, right?
You have people that are, you know, that go really hard on the recon stuff.
And you've got people that, that go really hard on the, you know, on the, on the manual hacking stuff.
Right.
Yeah.
And so there's definitely different types of hackers, but I've seen you do, do both.
And I think when you've got someone that they can do both, it creates a crazy result.
So, but I did want to ask you, you know, if you identify a little bit more as, as one or the other, do you, do you identify a little bit more as a manual hacker or as a one?
A, a wide hacker, you know, focusing on recon to find weird stuff, or do you see yourself as a mix of the two?
So I, I began mostly.
So I think it's, it's a matter of difference in terms of like where I'm at.
Yeah.
So I would say I started off, of course, manual because everybody does that.
You need to figure out what to do before you can automate it.
Sure.
I then went into like full, full on automation.
Like I wanted, but, but there was always like, I always had the argument on like, you can't automate if you don't know what you're looking for.
And if your whole idea is to find something you don't know of, you can't really automate it all.
So I was never, I was never a full on automation list.
If that's the word.
I was more on like, I automated a bunch of things.
I knew what I was looking for, but then I always kept this thing where like, I'm going to save it all.
And I'm going to look through it.
And I'm going to see the oddities myself.
Because I don't know what, what I will find.
The things will happen much faster than my knowledge about what it, what it is basically.
But then, then it came, I think it happened.
I took a break from bug hunting or like break.
It was probably like one and a half year or something like probably during COVID mostly.
Yeah.
Where, where I, I didn't want to do any live hacking events.
I wasn't really looking for bugs in, in any way during almost two years.
Yeah.
And when I came back, I kind of realized that similar to, I think what other bug hunters that like want to start off realize is that there's so many people that are doing automation.
That is like ridiculous.
Like seriously, like they, they do things so fast.
I, I tend to, I spoke a lot about my automation back in the day and I told them like, yeah, I'm, I'm doing like every eight hours I'm looking and they're like every eight hours I'm doing it every 20 minutes.
And I'm like, you know, like, yeah, exactly.
And I'm like, they're like, you're missing out on so many things.
I'm like, I can imagine.
Yeah.
And I'm like, do I want to invest the time to like speed up my, my automation just for those bugs?
And I, it came to the conclusion that like, no, I don't, I, I rather, I rather spend, you know, manual time trying to figure out really cool bugs than trying to like, like reach to the point where I'm like at length.
Where I'm like at level with other automationists.
Yeah.
No automation is, I love that word.
I think we're going to coin that term.
Arts and automation.
Automationists.
You know?
Yeah.
I, I, and it's actually funny, you know, I actually had that exact same path, you know, except I sort of skipped to the part where I was doing manual hacking in the beginning.
Like when, because there were so many resources by the time I started, you know, when I started, I guess in 2017, 2018, you know, you had already put out talks, you know, people were putting out talks on how to do stuff.
So I had a pretty decent flow of like bug bounty write ups and stuff like that to read.
And then I leveraged into automation, but then I came to the same conclusion you did, which is like, well, maybe a little bit different of one, but essentially, you know, in order to compete at this, at this game at the top level, you have to be constantly refactoring your code.
Yeah.
And it's a grind, right?
And it, and it's going to make it more of a pro, you're going to become more of a programmer than you are of a hacker, because, you know, you're constantly having to refactor code.
Yeah.
And, and so I also sort of leveraged a little bit more, or switched over into, into manual hacking a little bit more.
And it's been fun to see, see the results of that as well.
Yeah.
I think like, and when I also, when I think about it, like when I mentally think about like, what do I want to, like, what do I want to do?
Like, end up with, or like, what do I want to succeed with?
It's not that I like, oh, I, I dream of finding a unclaimed F3 bucket.
Like that's, that's really not the bug that I'm, I'm like, I will go home.
Exactly.
And be happy about the bug.
I will go home, be happy about is the one where I'm like, I did this thing over there.
And that gave me a little piece of the puzzle.
And then I went over there and did that.
And now I can access the server, like with an RC.
Like those are the kinds of bugs that I'm like, oh, I'm going to feel so proud.
And it's like, it's going to, it's going to hold up for, you know, more than a week, probably sometimes a year.
That bug has the value of like, and I will not find that by writing automation and finding an unseen bucket or, you know, environment variable file laying somewhere that might be helpful into doing other things.
But, you know, it's the fun, the fun things happen when, when I go deep.
So I absolutely shifted over to like, go deep, deep, full on, you know, go, you know, so deep that, that people are like, but move on, man.
Like, stop looking at that thing.
But, but I'm like, keep digging.
And like something, sometimes there's something falling out from it.
And like, you realize, you know, and I have, I have all these examples of, you know, running on the private program, but, but still, you know, grinding it for, for months.
And, and even collaborating with, with Matthias in this case.
And like, we couldn't figure, figure one thing out.
And it was like, how does this work?
And why is it happening?
And like, he was, he was at a concert.
I think it was, I don't know if it was like Iron Maiden or something, but he was at a concert and I was writing him messages because we often chat without the other one responding.
Like that's how we communicate.
Async.
Asynchronous, very, very much asynchronous.
And I was writing to him like, okay, but this worked.
Like, I don't know.
And, and like, it took probably two or three hours and that chat message history is like, is a beauty of itself because it's like this happened.
I think it, this, oh my God.
Like it ended up in like being like a whole disaster.
And, and it was like, you know, ring the bells.
And it was like, like one of the most beautiful bugs I've ever seen.
And it was just, just that grind of like, we've been having this for, for months knowing that there's something there, but we couldn't figure it out.
And then came to that conclusion.
It's like, it's so beautiful.
And it's, and it's like, that's the kind of bugs I want to come like, like continue to, you know, bring home or, you know, talk about in, in the future.
Yeah, absolutely.
I feel like for a long time, there was this, like, there was a lot of manual hacking that went on.
And then there was like a few years, kind of like right before COVID, like around COVID.
And then like during COVID where like a lot of people realize that there's so much scope and there's so much stuff out there that you can make a lot of money just by doing automation.
And like automation isn't a particularly difficult thing.
There's a lot of tools out there, stuff like nuclei and all these like frameworks and things that exist that let you kind of just like duct tape and bootstrap stuff together and just like build these little pipelines that do like a lot of like really efficient work.
And so a lot of people just really like dove headfirst into that and just started like scanning for stuff, finding subdomain takeovers, finding bucket takeovers, finding like, you know, CVEs that you could just like automate into, you know, easily reproducible reports and bugs.
And like, that's a, it's almost like a separate bug bounty space.
Absolutely.
Like you're basically at this point, you're not really like fighting over like complexity of bugs or like how this app like interacts with other parts of the app or how that service or this website might like, you know, be leveraged by another part of the application or another part of the company.
It's more just like how fast is your tooling and like how good can, can you beat the other person?
Is your internet better?
Is, you know, are you, is your scanning faster?
Are you looking at the right things?
Yes.
And I agree.
I really love this manual hacking type of mentality.
Like me and Justin have discussed this a little bit because as a full time hunter, I think it's a lot easier to either fall more towards automation or at least towards like less complex findings because you need that cashflow.
You need to be having reports going in all the time.
Sure.
But I also like, I love not feeling obligated to have reports in because that gives you that opportunity to do what you're talking about, like go deep with the application, get intimate as we like to say.
Get intimate with the application.
Absolutely.
And just like really like learn the ins and outs of this application, become like almost a developer essentially at the company where you understand more about how stuff is going on in the back end than even somebody who works at the company does.
Because that really gives you all those insights into where stuff is like faltering or where there might be weird mechanisms or the systemic patterns like you talked about where, you know, you realize, oh, this is like a common mistake or pitfall that they've made.
Maybe they made this here and here and here and so on.
I just love that that mentality of just like, you know, ignore the sort of the flash and the glamour and stuff, but it's just like bug after bug after bug and find that really, really cool deep shit.
And I agree.
I think I think one of the so I want full bug hunting mode last, I would say in beginning of September, October, kind of and and the decision I made was happening during that summer.
And because I had those kind of, you know, anxious things also like will I be able to like pay my own salary or like how can I figure out the economics around doing this full time.
And at that point, I I had I had luck because I I done like I did a few Zoom like bugs on Zoom and they paid me out that summer and they paid really well for those bugs.
So at that point, I'm like, okay, this is my buffer.
So I have a buffer now of like if I would take like my normal salary, I would I would like last these amount of months.
Okay, so these months I can I can figure out if I should, you know, go automation or continue doing because those bugs I found was like no automation was just like trying to figure out how everything works.
And I use that time to like figure out first, like where should I hunt?
Like what program takes care of me?
What program, you know, treats my bug bugs in a way that I feel appreciated or like they value my my time.
And then also like economical wise, like where should I spend my time to like align the return on investment in a way that makes me not stressed, you know, going forward.
And when I figure those things out, like where to look, I still trying to figure out like what programs I should focus on.
But when I figured out some of it, at least that helped me a lot in into like deciding that going deep was actually, you know, monetary wise, a good decision for me to like, don't be afraid that that I won't be able to pay myself a salary.
Yeah, yeah, I think you definitely see if you look at the numbers, I think you'll see a higher return on investment of time, right?
And a higher hourly rate if you do deep bugs.
But the thing with with automation is you get to have this and I experienced this when I was in automation game.
If you take time off, you still get bugs, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Which is just huge for like relief, right?
You know, like, I don't know what it is for me, but like, even if I have a ton of money sitting in the bank, if I see that trending downward while I'm taking a break, or if I if I know like, hey, I'm not finding bugs right now.
That just bothers me, you know, and I can imagine it's kind of like a it's it's definitely a psychological problem, you know, for sure.
But because I think you should be able to rest in both states, whether you just popped, you know, 100 K and bugs and now you take, you know, a couple weeks off and you've got that 100 K sitting in the bank and you're like, all right, I'm fine.
Or whether you've got, you know, 20 K in the bank and you're you see it going up and up and up and up with the bugs, you know, those are the same the same things.
But, you know, psychologically, it's it's it's very different, I think.
I think we also have a whole episode about like picking the right program.
And I think you covered this a little bit, but it's really important, especially like when you're doing full time hacking to have the right program.
Yeah, you mentioned like once you find like a program who really respects you as a researcher and your reports and like handles the things that you're submitting and takes it very seriously.
And it's like, you know, responsive and all these types of things like it makes a really big difference to like I almost want to say that it increases the quality of the bugs that you find later on.
Because like you have this relationship with the company where you want to show them like, hey, I found this really cool thing on on your app.
Like, let me show you like let me take it one step further.
Like, let me, you know, I bet you thought that last bug was cool.
But how about this? Yeah, exactly.
It's almost like a challenge. Yeah.
And if you find a company that that not only treats you right, but pays correctly, like if you have a program, say they pay like 5K crits and their mediums are like 750.
A couple of media like, you know, you're like five mediums, you're almost there. Right.
And so it's like if you have automation that's finding a bunch of mediums versus it takes you a week or two to find like a really bad crit, but it's only going to get paid 5K.
Then that trade off isn't always worth it.
But if you have a program that's paying like 30K crits and maybe their mediums are like one or 2K.
Well, that makes a big difference.
And then your time is really, really worth like spending that time finding that critical and not spending it doing automation or like trying to find a subdomain takeover.
Yeah. Let me jump in here and say, you know, I think we've made it clear enough, but I want to clarify.
We have tremendous respect for people on both sides of the game.
Sure. You know, and you know, there's definitely so many challenges of recon and so many challenges of deep diving stuff.
So hopefully this has given a little bit of insight into the thought, because I think all of us, Joel more so than me, but, you know, have leveraged a little bit more into the whole finding very high impact bugs, you know, with the majority of your time and Franz as well.
And so, okay, but we've already been talking for a while and I'm two bullet points down on my little list.
So let me, let me, let me, let me, let me just start the episode.
He's like, we got so much to cover for like 30 minutes.
We've talked about two topics.
Yeah. I'm like super stressed over here.
Bam, bam, bam.
Let me get back to my list. Okay.
Yeah.
No. Okay.
So I do want to ask a couple of things and we'll keep these pretty, pretty rapid fire, I think.
So, you know, you said you, you identify more now as, as sort of a deep, deep dive hacker, which I think is, is on point.
And so, and I think I know the answer to this cause you already alluded to it, but I'm wondering,
how much time it takes you to how much time you normally spend on a program on average and how much time it normally takes you to find some bugs that you're proud of.
I would say, so I haven't jumped between programs that much since I started with this methodology, but the, the times I've done it during these two years, I would say.
I think, and this is like where the imposter syndrome also hits hard every time it's because whenever you change your switch program, you basically have these, you know, sometimes for me, it can take up to like three days until I actually find, you know, something that I, I think is relevant or valuable.
Yeah. And so, so, and I, I train myself to not like, I, you know, you feel shit.
Oh yeah. Yeah.
Like you hate yourself and you think you're a fraud and you know, all these kind of, you know, thoughts come up.
But at some point you're like, okay, but no, I, I know this time is there.
You need to invest the time.
And you know, because, and it's interesting also because if you compare the first day, you see a bunch of, you know, variable names or like parameter names and like, what, what is this?
What is this?
I have no idea.
I just want to find a bug, like ignore what they are like.
And the third day you're like, oh, I know exactly what that parameter does.
Yeah.
What it does.
Okay.
So that's why, so you need to like spend those three days to like get that, you know, mindset of like, like the taxonomy, for example, taxonomy is a huge, huge thing.
Like what do they call, you know, this kind of object and like as soon as, so I, I tend to like write down taxonomy for myself just to like understand.
What is referencing what then at some point, like that's also a really good receipt for, okay, they're calling it a little bit different here.
Yeah.
They use, they use, you know, a Pascal case over here, but there's snake case over there.
And like those kinds of things is like indicators that there are multiple people doing, doing things here and they've named it differently.
Like that's an indicator.
Yeah.
And those things takes probably like three days to realize that this is an outlier.
So let me, let me just highlight that just for the listeners.
Okay.
Do you guys hear the level of depth that he's, he's describing here?
He's describing the, the case, the case of parameters.
And he, and, and he's, he's taking notes on the, the verbiage, the, the wording, the taxonomy of the various parameters and, and, and points.
And, and this is the kind of stuff that you would think is getting too minute, too, too detailed, but it's totally not.
No, no, because every single, every single thing, every time you go that deep, you get a further and further, a little bit, little, just a little, little tiny bit closer to understanding what it's, what it's looking like for this whole application.
And, and that, that little step, little step by step there makes all the difference in the world when it comes to sort of black box texting.
When at the end of the day, you're totally, you know, you're totally looking at a black box, you know, you have no idea what you're working on.
So, um, there's some, there's some good tricks.
There's some good tricks.
The three day number.
I'm with you, man.
Like I, I, yeah.
Yeah.
I mean, there's some good tricks you can do.
Like sometimes I just take the full scope and I, I search for the host in burp search, and then I copy everything into an XML file and I have like an unpack, uh, unpack burp state or unpack burp list.
Uh, and then I share the body of the request and then I take all the words I have, and then I sort them and make them unique.
And then I can see like, okay, there's like intent ID, but there's intent underscore ID.
And then suddenly I can like go that way to like find oddities in, in parameters as well.
Yeah.
And, and those are those, you know, if you've got intent ID snake case in intent underscore ID, you know, those are per parameters that were clearly implemented by different developers, right?
Or, or different, you know, um, life cycle flows right, right there.
Right.
And so, um, you know, there's definitely a good chance that if every single intent uppercase I ID is secure, that sometimes the intent underscore ID will not be secure.
So having that, that sort of frameworks in place can really help you, um, understand, you know, that, that from a holistic perspective.
And just taking, you know, also, I just want to shout out that, that ability to take notes to, to, or not necessarily take notes, but like to process the data that you've got there, you know, exporting to burp, taking the time to write the XML unpack script, which is something I've never done by the way, because it's just such a pain in the ass.
I can share it.
It's awesome.
Yeah, that would be great.
Um, yeah, it is something that will differentiate you from other hackers, right?
You don't even have to know that it's the right thing to do.
You know, so many people are like, man, should I spend my time doing this?
It doesn't matter.
It's going to make you unique as a hacker.
Let's say you do that.
Nothing comes of it.
You still saw more of the application than someone else who, who hasn't done that.
Right.
You, you looked at those parameters a little bit differently, you know, because you unpacked everything.
So it's the things that make us unique hackers like that, that, that really allow different people to find different crazy bugs.
Yeah.
I also think that there's like a whole aspect, like the whole becoming almost like a developer,
within that environment where if you learn the terminology and you learn what things mean, so many developers use abbreviations and stuff to like represent things like they, they might, uh, you know, take something that represents some system.
Right.
They might abbreviate it as three characters and just start using that as an acronym, like throughout their application, throughout different, like, you know, endpoints or parameter calls and stuff.
A lot of times I'll look at something like that and I'll say like, what, like, what is, what is this? Like, what is this? These three letters, what is this supposed to mean?
Like, what, what does this represent to the developer?
And once you identify at a lower level, like, what does this actually mean? What are they referencing when they're saying, you know, these three characters or whatever, you can really start to unpack hidden functionality and this type of stuff that may even exist that, you know, you'll start to stretch to different ideas.
Like, oh, maybe if they're calling, uh, an endpoint with a different three letter acronym, maybe I can toss my three letter acronym that I know what this means.
Maybe I can hit a different service or something.
Right.
And I, and I think like getting to that level of just being like, what does that mean? Or what is this parameter doing? Or what, what does this represent can let you get that much deeper understanding and be able to dive deeper within the application so much easier.
Yeah.
A hundred percent.
Um, so let me, let me ask this then.
Um, I, I have seen.
I mean, I'm thinking specifically at the last live hacking that we were both at when we were sitting at this table and we were like slamming our heads into a wall, um, on this one specific bug for awhile.
Um, how, how often do you find yourself sitting in front of a request and trying things sort of incessantly versus sitting back, staring at the ceiling and thinking about the bug?
Like, and, and, and I, and I know that this is kind of a hard question cause it's very, um, you know, abstract, but just give me your gut, your gut feelings on how much time you spend actually hands-on iterating versus, uh, just sort of thinking and ideating.
Yeah.
So, so, so I have, I have a bunch of things I, I tend to do when I, I get to the point where I, I can't figure it out.
Like it's all everything from, you know, collecting my own kind of word list from that, uh, asset just to like find, you know, things in there that like can make me understand.
Sure.
This is, uh, up to, up to the point where, where, as you said, like, I, I take a walk and I'm like thinking about it and like, how, why does it behave like it does?
Or what is it trying to, you know, what data is it trying to fetch or, or similar?
Or similar.
So sometimes I would say both work, uh, sometimes, you know, complete brute, uh, together with very context related information.
Yeah.
Like for example, generic word lists for me is not really helping that much.
I wouldn't say that, you know, word lists found on, you know, a really large word, word list works that well.
I would, the ones that work are, are when, when you can like apply the context to what you're actually looking at.
That's when you're getting the nice, nice hits.
And, and, but, but in, in, in, in the other aspect also, it's like, sometimes you just need to think about it and, you know, Google error messages is like an awesome thing as well.
As soon as you see an error message that is like, this is not a generic error message.
Like then you can start digging down, like maybe it's this and maybe this is the database I'm injecting into or whatever.
Or even maybe an error message that kind of looks like a generic error message, but it's worded specifically.
Yes.
You know, or it has like, you know, a format that is, that is very, very different from also like if error messages looked the same on a target and suddenly one error message doesn't.
That is, that is also like, okay.
The, all the other ones have, you know, square brackets around the error code, but this one does not.
Like those could be also indicators that, okay, there's another thing causing this error message.
Yeah.
No, absolutely.
Absolutely.
I think like one of the really underutilized things is Googling stuff with quotes around it.
Yeah.
Absolutely.
Exactly.
Like we did that at the last event, you know, the thing that we're talking about right now, it's like, what is this?
Like, what is this system?
What is this using?
What is this technology?
And just search the error message and immediately there's a hundred Google results all mentioning the same exact thing.
You're like, oh, okay.
It's not.
Okay.
That's it.
So last question about the hacker methodology piece.
So it seems like you spend a good amount of time on your targets.
Sure.
Give me just sort of like a gut feeling on like how, how much time you spend on the average target.
I would say, so I would say three days is, is an investment first.
You might not get anything from it.
So I've done this like short assessments kind of thing where I'm like, okay, I'm going to focus on this program.
And what, what has happened for me is like one and a half week.
Yeah.
It's, it's, it's a, it's a time for me where I know I'm going to find something good.
Yes.
I don't know how bad it will be, but I know I will find something that will be good.
So one and a half week has been a really good way for me, but also like you have kids.
So it's like, right.
You don't know where, where you're going to spend that one and a half week.
Right.
Are you going to spend it on the night?
Are you going to spend it, you know, in the office times or are you going to spend it like at all?
Like there could be, you know, and, and often like when you submit, you know, a bunch of bugs at the same time, or like in the, in the matter of, of days, you always have this triage, you know, massage.
Yeah.
That is like, it can be, especially like my, my reports are like sometimes two to 4,000 words.
Uh, my, my reports are insane, man.
Like they are, they are, my blog posts are sometimes are small compared to my blog posts.
Oh my God.
I'm writing them manually.
It's not like copy pasting a boilerplate of like how it's actually like step-by-step showing, you know, sometimes I'm showing even how I came to the conclusion that there's, there's a bug.
And I share like a very long impact explanation and you know, everything is like typed from, from, from the frontal cortex.
Yeah.
Right.
A hundred percent.
Yeah.
But, but, so, but then you have, so that half week afterwards is like three triage massage, basically.
Like getting through, they find out it's not a dupe and then it's another week of, yes, this is how you reproduce it.
Yeah.
Have you tried this?
That's a good, that's a good side effect also of going like deep into a program, like compare, like live hacking events are, are an exception to the, to the rule.
Yeah.
But, but I haven't duped once in, in all, all like this full time since August last year, uh, except for live hacking.
You've duped me, you stupid.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
Like I was like, Oh yeah.
So let's say for example, that program, right?
That was a, that was a challenge.
Um, and, and so how long would you spend on something like that?
That one I spent, I, I, to be honest, that one was new for me, so I didn't know what to expect.
So I submitted that bug only.
Uh, and it was two hours or something.
Yeah.
I mean, I didn't spend shit on that.
But the funny thing was that it was, I think it was very valuable for me not to spend more time because I had a hunch that they might not be as, you know, receptive to that vulnerability, receptive to the report as I thought.
So in, in that sense, I think I did a good investment not to spend more time.
Yeah.
And that's also a thing where you like, especially when it comes to new programs, I'm like very, very restrictive on like, like the worst thing you can do is like, you spend much time, you find a really bad bug and then you continue and you submit bugs and you have no response yet.
And you're like investing so much time and then suddenly they respond and they don't treat you in a good way.
Yeah.
And you're like, why did I continue?
You spoke really wisely.
I've heard that before from, from other people in the, in the, in the podcast also, it's like, do don't invest too much in the beginning.
Like you won't, you won't gain anything from submitting, you know, 50 bugs in the beginning.
You're, you're only gambling with your own time.
Like don't do that.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
And you can gamble with that time when you know the receiver and you know what, what to expect from them.
You have to validate, validate the program and validate your threat model because on one hand, you know, you could be, it could be the program just being shit, right?
That's one possibility.
You know, they could just be a bad program.
Or do you have misaligned your, exactly.
Exactly.
What they think is a threat or not.
Or you could have misaligned your threat model.
And, and, and that's not anybody's fault, except maybe, you know, one could argue that the team should have, uh,
you know, provided more insight into their threat model.
Sure.
In their policy, which I would love to see more of in general, but you know, like you said, it's a gamble.
If you're not, if you're not, you know, validating that threat model in advance, because, um, you know, it's very easy for issues to, to come out of that.
Um, for sure.
And so, okay.
All right.
First section of my, of my, of my notes are, are done here.
Yes.
Um, so here's what, here's where I'm thinking we're going to go from here.
Okay.
I have, uh, compiled together.
Let's see.
One, two, three, four, five, six, uh, articles.
Some of the best hacking articles I've ever read written by Franz over the years, starting in 2017, spanning all the way up to, I think 2022 or 2023, the latest one.
Um, and I just want to kind of walk through these and talk about mentality.
I want to talk about the technical details of them.
So I hope you reviewed them because I don't know about you, but I, if I, if I wrote something, you know, six months ago and then somebody asked me about it, you know, six months later, then I'm screwed.
Uh, cause I don't remember anything, but we'll see.
Um, okay.
So the first one, and we'll link all these in the description as well.
I would, it's not even something that I would recommend.
It is mandatory reading for any listener of critical thinking to go and read all of these.
Um, so please keep that in mind.
Um, the first one that I wanted to talk about was this whole, uh, AWS S3 thing.
So, um, if any, you know, for the listeners here, um, S3 bucket takeovers and S3 bucket issues now are what it's one of the most hottest.
It's one of the hottest topics in, in cloud security.
Um, and all of this originates with this man right here, Franz, um, who, who sort of coined the S3 bucket.
Thanks for the credit.
Yeah.
The S3 bucket takeover.
Um, and so I, I want to kind of, you know, flashback to 2017 here.
Um, you're seeing this new technology sort of coming on the scene and you're seeing it implemented in lots of different places on all these different programs.
How do you come, how do you identify this issue?
So it was actually earlier, it was actually 2014.
Wow.
The first, the first blog post about it was in 2014, October, I think.
Yeah.
Um, and, and back then, back then it was basically, you know, every time you saw a 404, you like, just like moved on.
Yeah, exactly.
Because it's like, wasn't nothing is there.
Right.
Uh, so I, I think we, we came to the conclusion.
Like, I think it was both S3 and there was some, something else that was also like, I think Heroku was, and GitHub pages was one of those.
So I think we just came to the realization because we were looking at like the tech to five was, was getting built at the same time.
And a lot of things we were doing was around, you know, finding sub domains and, and trying to identify what, what they were running.
And at some point, I think we, we figured out that like, okay, so, uh, we started signing up on these, these, uh, you know, I think Shopify as well, like this, this sauce services.
And suddenly realized that you could just like, there were no verification at all.
Like we were under the, like assumption in the beginning that you need to validate your, your, that you own the domain because that's how you do, you know, everything else when it comes to like Gmail or, you know, when you want to run Gmail, for example.
And, and, and, and realize that, okay, nobody's actually doing this because it's like a convenience thing to, to like not use that validation part.
And we started reaching out to all these companies and writing like, okay, somebody can just hijack all these, these, uh, companies, uh, because they're pointing to you.
And some of these, some of the providers were just like, yeah, but they're not our customer anymore.
So why like reading between the lines, that was what they were saying.
Like, it's not our fault that, you know, they're not paying us anymore or, you know, somebody's going to have to pay us to hack them.
I like that.
It's not our customer.
Yeah.
Go for it.
No, but so, so I think, and, and, and a lot of them were like, we already know about this.
This is no, no big deal.
And, and we were, we were screaming loud, like, please do something about it.
Like add the validation, do, you know, whatever, like something you need to do something.
And, and when everybody responded, like not a single company responded with like, yeah, you're right.
Oh my gosh.
We, we realized like, I, we need to get it, get it out there.
And then it was just a matter of like, how many more are there?
And I think the first blog post we had, we had like 14, maybe providers, like big providers that we decided to, to announce.
Uh, but at the same time, there were, you know, a huge amount popping up since then, of course, still popping up to this day.
And, uh, and S3 is one of those that, that like keeps on lingering.
Uh, I know that there are, there are some.
Changes happening or like, you can't change S3, but you can, you can do implementations above it.
That is like safe.
So there's something called S3 access points, which is, uh, their addition to it and access points always get like a unique, um, hash in the, in it.
So you can't reclaim an access point.
So that's, that's like AWS solution to the problem needs to like make access point.
Access point, uh, the way to actually access a bucket.
Um, but yeah, I think, and like one of the big challenges in the beginning also, when it comes to S3 was to figure out what the bucket name was.
Uh, it wasn't always clear, uh, even though you have it in the error message, it wasn't always clear, uh, what the bucket.
And especially sometimes you do want to know the bucket name, even if it's, uh, exists.
And I think that was the, the, the whole idea with the bucket this close was to figure out what the bucket was named, because if you knew what the bucket was named, you can make additional API calls on the side, uh, to that bucket to see access level errors and stuff.
Yeah.
Um, that's, that's such an amazing little, little script there.
Um, and we'll, we'll link it down below.
Yeah.
We'll link it down below and it does still work to allow you to identify what the name of a bucket is.
And there's lots of really cool error based stuff you can do with that too, where you're like creating, um, invalid signed URLs that fail in such a specific way that it like leaks the bucket name.
So cool.
We have the same, I love this.
Me and Mattias built the same one in the beginning of this year for, uh, Google cloud storage.
Nice.
So we have, uh, we have seven, seven, the cloaking methods for, for, uh, for, uh, cloud storage.
Uh, and it's kind of helpful in cloud storage as well, because sometimes you really want to know the name and it's very important for depending on how your setup looks like.
So I think I will talk with Mattias to get it out as well.
I think it's very fun to have.
That's awesome.
De-cloaking.
I love the, the, that like terminology.
Yes.
I think this applies to more than just S3 buckets where like, it's, it's very similar to like origin server detection, where, you know, if you're trying to bypass a WAF, for example, you find what the origin is.
Is there a way to talk to the origin server directly and mimic is if your requests are going through the wrap WAF, then oftentimes you can just bypass the WAF directly.
And it's very similar to like S3 where you might have some sub domain that's maybe it's talking to a backend service instead of actually just being a C name, um, to the bucket directly.
Yeah.
And if you can figure out some way to error it or, you know, get, get it to basically Oracle to what the bucket is, then you can, you know, maybe read some data that you shouldn't have access to.
You can list the bucket and maybe you can do, you know, whatever.
It really depends on the context.
Yes.
I love that, that methodology.
Yeah.
The decloaking is, is applicable in so many aspects, like you mentioned as well, like with a reverse proxy or an origin structure, you know, if you can leak that backend URL, there's, there's a decent chance that you might be able to use that in a V host, you know, somewhere else at a load balancer level and hit that backend server directly.
And just bypass all of the middleware authentication that they've got in place.
Yes.
So we've seen that time and time again, and it's a, it's an awesome technique.
And, and that's another one of the things that kind of comes out of the security research is, is the, the impact, the, the conceptual impact is very wide reaching, right?
Yeah.
It's applicable to lots of different areas, which is, which is really cool.
Um, okay.
So there's lots of other stuff you can dive into with this, with this blog post that will link the, and actually I didn't even have the one I'm looking back now.
Cause you said there's one in 2014 and then there's also another one, which I missed in 2016, where you're talking about cloud front stuff.
And, um, Oh yeah.
And.
Oh, that was fun.
Yeah.
That was good memories.
And the, the, the, uh, the trailing dot dude.
Yeah.
Like, oh, yeah.
There was a bug, there was a bug like in a live hacking event, right?
Yeah.
Just like two years ago or something that, that one of the bugs, the best bugs in that live hacking event was a trailing dot.
So it still happened.
For those of you, excuse me, for those of you that don't know about that, actually, you know, Franz, why don't you tell them a little bit about trailing dot and what that does conceptually?
Yeah.
So I think the blog post mentioned specifically cloud front.
So what happened with cloud front was that when you went to, uh, in this case, it was like, uh, paypal.com.
It wasn't paypal.com.
I think it was card.com.
So you went to card.com and you would be served a page through cloud flare.
Uh, but the whole idea with like how internet works or like the dub dub dub works was that, uh, you can always add a trailing dot.
Yeah.
So the only one thing that I wanted to qualify the main name is actually ending with a dot.
Mm.
Uh, they've just removed it for like, I think for like simplicity or something.
Yeah.
Uh, so a trailing dot should always, you know, serve similar things or just give an error or whatever.
And in cloud front, it gave an error, but it gave the error that looked like nobody has claimed that domain.
Mm.
So I went into cloud front.
Now you can't do this anymore because cloud front wants you to validate that you own the domain.
But back then you could just add it as a scene into cloud front and it had like a client side validation.
So you couldn't add a trailing dot.
It would say you can't, but if you'd like capture the proxy, if you take the, like, it was like a G G RPC request and you might have to go.
Yeah.
One of the things we're going to talk about a little bit later, assuming we don't have to
cut for time, is this middleware misconfigurations that you talked about.
Yeah.
It's like a functional, functional language because you can pipe everything through everything.
Like it's, it's like, that's where Python, Python script into some other Python.
I mean, but, but now you get like your whole script is based on piping data through,
you know, conversions and things.
So I think, I think it's just, uh, my mentality is not like, this is a script and this is a pipeline
with the script.
Like my script is my pipeline or often I think it's like an organic thing of like my, my, my
script is becoming, it's becoming a script because I use the pipeline and now I'm like,
so I think it's just my mentality of like, that's an, I think I, I tend to use it so much
also because it's like, it's goes so fast on building it.
Yeah.
Uh, you know, we'll, we'll, we'll roll away.
We'll let you, we'll let that fly.
We'll let that slide.
No worries.
Um, and we'll, I wanted to talk to you about collaboration in live hacking events.
And I want to read a quote from, um, the, the, this article and you give a lot of great
advice, uh, in this article or in this, um, in this slide deck about, um, essentially doing
the work that other people aren't willing to do.
Uh, um, focusing on the boring stuff and, and, you know, configuring all the things that other hackers won't configure.
That's the way to get the big bounties and the way to hit sort of untapped attack surface.
And that's great.
So I wanted to shout that out, but I also wanted to talk about this section where you said, uh,
when you're talking about teaming, cause teaming is something that we talk about on critical thinking a lot.
Joel and I, Joel is one of the few people, um, actually one of the only people I think that I have ever done six, in my opinion,
successfully done a, a collaboration with over the past five years where it was a full from the beginning to the end collaboration.
Right.
Um, yeah.
And I think that's because I've been burned a little bit in the past on large teams.
Um, and, and that, that is what it is.
Everyone needs to have that learning experience, but I get a little bit of a bad rap for being anti collaboration.
Now I'm not anti collaboration by any stretch.
Um, but you give some really great advice here.
So let me read that with regards to teaming team up with someone that is not going to be a good
one will put similar effort into as you, two might know stuff.
You don't three helps you cover more attack surface for you can communicate with and brain stream or brain stream, uh, brainstorm.
And then you say, yeah, right.
Exactly.
Uh, if you look at, uh, freaking Matias's DMS, it might be, you seem more of a brain stream than a brainstorm.
I mean, it makes sense.
Brainstream also.
Um, and then you say, keep, keep teams small two to four.
If three or more effort will differ, allow splitting differently for two people.
50% is always the simplest.
So that was sort of like the brain dump of, of collaboration wisdom you did back in the day.
Do you still hold to all that?
Absolutely.
A hundred percent.
I think, and I, I think it's very interesting also in terms of like where, uh, when, like, I do try to collaborate with new people all the time.
Um, and, and, you know, once or twice, sometimes maybe around one bug and sometimes maybe, you know, during an event or during just a target, sometimes even.
And I always come to the conclusion that it's like a lot easier to do it to people, uh, because then it's, it's much easier to, you know, it's very simple.
Then if, if both are collaborating, then, then the full team is there.
But if you're three, maybe two of them are working together one night, the other one can't.
And like, it's, it's, it just after two, it becomes like really hard to align that everybody's doing equal work because you do.
You don't want to get, end up in like me personally would not like to end up in the, in the scenario where I get paid for doing nothing.
Uh, and I hope that other people don't feel great about that either.
It's like, because I wouldn't, I, I, I, I sometimes feel bad with one person when that person is providing much more than I do.
Uh, but I, I, I at least try to put in the time trying to find things.
Uh, but so I, I struggle a lot with, uh, you know, often with like, I'm like, I don't need to be collaborator on this thing because I didn't do anything.
Uh, that kind of mentality, uh, myself.
So I really like, I enjoy people having the same kind of mentality themselves.
Uh, and you quite quickly notice the ones that don't really care and like almost gets to, you know, ride on a sandwich.
It's a Swedish prover, but, but like, uh, gets, gets to do things are getting paid for not doing it.
What the kind of proverb is that ride on a sandwich?
It's actually, it's actually ride on the shrimp sandwich.
What the frick?
Yeah.
It was like, yeah.
I don't, I, I, I, yeah, it's weird, but yeah.
So it's, I, I, I, and, and so that's why, like when you identify the people that like kind of align with you on those things, it becomes so much easier to like collaborate and like just focus on the fun stuff, which is the hacking part.
And, and try to, you know, find the best way, uh, to escalate the bug.
Yeah.
I mean, that's one of the things I really love about live hacking events is that I find that more often than not, any random person at a live hacking event that I walk up to, I'm able to almost like jump the line and get to a communication level that like, it's very hard to establish with other people just out of, out of the gate.
And part of that, I think is just that like, we all have a similar kind of technical background.
We all have a very common base of knowledge about like web security or just even just security in general and like the types of bugs and stuff.
And if you can get past that and just start talking immediately about like technical problems and being on the same page, that helps so much with actually making progress with bugs.
I see this all the time when me and Justin, uh, co-hack essentially where we'll sit down at a live hacking event and maybe one of us will drive and the other one's just really just like sitting there, like looking, like seeing and like the communication, like we don't even speak in sentences.
It's just like, yeah, yeah.
It'll be like, oh, that's really, yeah.
I mean, have we tried doing X, Y like, and we don't even like, we kind of just like, we're looking at the same thing.
We're consuming the same thing.
We can kind of jump through communication and almost in shortcuts.
Um, and I really love being able to do that when you get to like more and more people that starts to fall apart and it becomes less scalable.
I think probably the most you can do that with is maybe like four people where you have four people like sort of huddled around, like throwing ideas before you start to run into communication problems.
Not, not even just like the, the like barrier to, to communication, but just like too many people are talking at the same time or like there's too many ideas running around.
There's, or there's too many perspectives where it's like, we're not, you know, like we're never really going down a full path because somebody, you know, if three people think one thing and the other person's like, wow, but like, you know, what about this thing?
And then you get sidetracked.
So it definitely does work best with, with two, I think.
Yeah, for sure.
And I, I, the one, the, the times we've been for, it has naturally become, you know, pairs.
Uh, so you have two and two that is like very much.
Yeah.
And then we've had done, we have done some live hacking events for people, but sometimes in those, like, you, sometimes also like you need to be prepared to have like very tough.
Like if it goes well, you need to have tough discussions on like, Hey guys, me and, you know, X put in a little bit more time than you guys.
I, are you all like fine with us, you know, getting a larger percentage of whatever it is.
And, and, and those kinds of discussions.
And if you can't have those, or if they turn, you know, ugly, then it's going to be a really hard time to, to collaborate in the future.
But if you can have those great ones, then it doesn't, you know,
The reason, the reason I bring this topic up often on the podcast is because I want people to be aware of the fact that there, there are some sticky situations you can get into with this.
Absolutely.
So anyone going into collaboration needs to know that there's risk and there's reward.
Um, and, and you need to be ready to have these, these conversations.
And here's the other thing.
A lot of people will take the high road and say like, you know, it's, it's, it's just money.
You know, it's not a big deal, but I've found that those people will harbor resentment.
They'll, they'll leave that, that, that resentment in their heart.
Right.
And that, that's not, that's not.
Sometimes without knowing, even sometimes without knowing and that that's not helpful for the community, you know?
And, and so, no, I think, I think it's absolutely important to like, if you can feel that you dare to have that discussions with the people you collaborate with, that's a really good situation to be in.
Yeah.
Because if you feel that you can't take that up, uh, then maybe you should, I don't know.
Then it becomes like, if you, if you feel that like, I will put that back even personally, like I will avoid not saying anything, even though I feel bad.
Like, as you said, like you would feel bad going forward.
Like it's much better to like ease it up and say like, Hey guys, like I, I put in a lot of time in this and so did he or something.
Can we do something about it and let them, you know, see where they are, what they are suggesting, or, you know, maybe they are saying, yeah, we a hundred percent agree.
Then, okay.
Then you have, then you, you can align that.
And then everybody's happy.
Yeah.
Um, these problems, you don't really have these problems when, uh, when you don't find bugs though.
That's true.
Like these are, these are like the happy problems.
Yeah.
It's good problems to have.
And it's really good to train yourself to have those discussions because you might get stepped on if not, and that's not a great feeling to have either.
So, um, so I know some people are like trying to measure how much work they put in compared to each other and stuff, but I don't, I don't think that's a, that's a good way either.
Yeah, I agree.
It's just going to get dirty.
I agree.
But, but I, I think it's, it's all around finding the people that you know are putting in the time that you, and you need to try, right?
You need to try with, with people and, and collaborate.
And sometimes you find those matches.
Like me and Shubs hadn't collaborated, but we did last year for my first time.
And like, after that we've been collaborating maybe once a month, sometimes more.
And it's like, it's so easy to do it together.
We were like, and also like him, him in Australia, like I have a bug.
I go to bed.
I write to him before I go to bed.
Like, this is what I found.
I wake up and he like, I found it.
I was like, but like, this is magic.
Like, this is such a good collaboration and, and turning, turn the high into a crit just because like he found something I didn't.
And that's just the power of collaboration.
Me and Mattias does that every single day.
So it's, it's such a, such a great thing to, to be able to utilize.
Yeah.
I love that about collaborating.
Like often when I find somebody who's, who I collaborate with really well together, it's not like, it's not so much like, I don't really think about who's found what bug or like, how should this be balanced?
It's like, usually if it's going really well, it's that we're both frustrated about like the same things.
And maybe like one person find something that's really critical.
But it's, it's never like, just like by themselves, like in a corner, like you two have both been putting in like a lot of the same amount of brain effort.
And for me, that's what really matters is like, absolutely.
Like what you said in your slide is like, find somebody who contributes like a similar amount of, like effort and, and, you know, time and that kind of stuff.
Because it's not really like how many bugs they're finding.
It's like, are you on the same page?
Are you both engaged at the same level?
Like, does it feel like we're both putting in the same amount of energy?
Because that combined energy will get satisfying outputs for both people.
Even if you didn't find the exact payload or whatever, like you were there the whole time.
Yeah, exactly.
And that's exactly a hundred, a hundred percent that.
And also like, I think with, with the whole collaboration thing, I mean, sometimes it's, it's like the, the wins you do together is it's like they last much longer than winning yourself.
Like they do.
And it's not, it's absolutely not only money mattering.
Like it's, it's actually like, we did this together.
We, we, we, we spent this time to like, we, we, we did all these things and that win is like so much bigger than, than doing it for sure.
Yeah, for sure.
I, you know, Joel, that, the, one of the most, um, foremost times that, that we collaborated together, that we did a full, a full split collab.
That is, that is one of my favorite life hack events I've ever done.
And my, I think I was asked recently in an interview, what's your favorite hacking memory?
The, the time that shell popped was my, my favorite hacking memory.
So.
Absolutely.
I think I remember this event.
Yeah.
It's, it's amazing.
You guys were similarly tired.
Yeah.
Okay.
So, um, I w so the middleware everywhere and lots of misconfigurations to fix blog post phenomenal.
I think we're going to skip it for now.
Um, we talked a little bit about it in the, you know, when we were talking about the service worker stuff and we're going to jump right to, um, account hijacking using dirty dancing and sign in a lot flows.
I want to get in some technical details here.
Yeah.
First.
I just got to say, I love this concept of breaking the state intentionally, right.
In, in, in OAuth flow.
Yeah.
Um, could you give us a, talk a little bit about that technique and why that's so helpful?
Cause I freaking love it.
Yeah.
So to be honest, when I found that, that it was a technique, I kind of like, yeah, obviously it is.
Uh, but I also realized like there's not that many things, uh, other than the post message that would be relevant for doing that or doing so.
Because there's not that much things other than post message today that might leak your full URL.
So the whole thing with, with OAuth breaking the state intentionally is basically that you often have this state parameter where combined with the code that you're getting back.
And the whole idea with the state parameter is, is that it's first initiated by the website that you're trying to sign into.
And then the state parameter basically just gets sent through the, the OAuth stands and then comes back identical to what you send, send it, the website sent it as.
And if it's matching, then it will go through the OAuth flow.
So it's a fully, it, the, the whole mitigation factor here is that if, if the website itself decides on a state specifically for this, uh, user, it can set the cookie or whatever to make sure that it's the,
the same state that comes back.
It's actually a mitigation to prevent, you know, uh, somebody to send you a link and, and get, get you to, to connect to their attacker account or, you know, a bunch of other C-Surf fish, uh, attacks with, with OAuth.
Uh, but the funny thing is that the whole implementation of validating the state is happening before you acquire the code, which is like the best thing for the attacker.
If you can leak through your URL, if you can get the victim to use your, your state instead, because then you can just take everything.
The, the code will never be used because the validation of the state is before.
It's gonna fail.
Yeah.
And, and then, and then you can take it and rerun the same code and it will work.
And you ignore the original state because you generated the original state.
Yeah.
I regenerated it and send it to the victim.
So the concept here is you've got an attacker.
He's positioned in such a way that he can redirect the victim somewhere.
So.
Or send the link to it.
Or send the link to them.
Send the link to the victim.
Yeah.
And, and, um, so they, they generate an OAuth flow URL that has a state that only the attacker knows.
Right.
And he gives it a different state to the victim.
And when the victim goes through and, and tries to even maybe use, exchange that code, plus the state for an, an auth token, once it bounces back from the OAuth provider, that, that will fail because the state does not match the,
the internal state, but, and then the code is just sitting in the fragment and then you can go and get that code and exchange that code.
Plus the state that, you know, for the, and I've actually seen some scenarios with this where when the OAuth flow fails, it will redirect to a different location.
Right.
And that can expose you.
Yeah.
Start sites.
Exactly.
That can expose that data to more, to more risks, which is rad.
Yes.
So.
Yeah.
And, and the, the, the funny part with the whole state thing is also like, you don't often times you don't, because there's a difference between if you get a code back in OAuth flow, you need to get the code to convert into an access token.
And, and most often you need to provide what redirect URI that was being used.
And if that redirect is differing from the redirect URI that was actually being used in the OAuth stands, you might not get the access token.
But breaking the state is like, you're ending up on the correct redirect URI.
Yeah.
It's there's like, that validation is just like completely avoided because the same redirect URI, you will end up on the same correct place.
And, and, and, but, but the state is the only thing that's breaking it.
It's awesome.
Yeah.
It's actually like one of the reasons why some of the parts are automated when it comes to dirty dancing gadgets and things, because what you can do is like, you can figure out if there are listeners when you're intentionally like changing the state in a login flow.
If there are listeners somewhere in that, you know, coming back on the error page, you can like easily figure out that something is there for investigation.
Yeah. So, you know, we, we talked about the ups and downs of, of doing the research in this article, which is phenomenal.
Yeah.
The other piece that I wanted to talk about was subbing the, the response type that to token slash ID token or ID token versus code and how that affects how the redirect URI is used.
Could you talk a little bit about that?
Sure.
I mean, the, the concept I found was that there are certain transfer mechanisms that the OAuth specification tells you to use depending on what type of data the OAuth provider is sending back to the website.
What that means is basically like, for example, if you use, if you want to get back an access token, the access token is never supposed to be sent as a query parameter.
It's actually supposed to be sent as a fragment part of the URL.
And the reason for that is basically that it doesn't show up in access logs on the website.
You can still reach it with JavaScript.
So the website can still get it, but it's not leaked to access logs or anything.
The fragment stays on the client side and it's client side script that needs to fetch it.
Same thing happens with ID token.
ID token is like a little bit in, little bit in between, but it tends to be more on the fragment side than, than on the, on the query parameter side.
But in addition to this, you have response modes and some of the response modes will fail.
If you try to, if you try, for example, to get like a, a token and you have a response mode query, sometimes response mode query is, is the thing.
Then you should be, you should getting an error.
You should, you should, you can get it through either through fragment or it's called web post or web message, I think, which is like actually sending data over through post message.
It all depends on the, on the OAuth provider, what they've decided on being the response modes.
Apple made up them their own.
There's also one called form post where it's posting, submitting the access token as, as a post request to the website.
And that one is, I think I mentioned it in the end as a potential exploitation factor because Google has, even though you have like really locked up redirect your eyes on.
Google has, on Google, you can still enable a mode with parameters that tells you that it should post, post the data as, as a post request, but then you can select whatever URL on the website you want, even subdomains.
What?
So that one is, is ripe for exploitation.
Absolutely.
I think that one is not supposed to work as it should.
Uh, I mentioned it because I wanted it to be fixed and I think, I do still think it's possible to, to utilize it.
The thing I found with it though, it's like, it's really, there you can talk about stars being aligned because you need something that either reflects post data.
Uh, in a way that you can read it somewhere else through post message or whatever.
So because post data, you can't read, reach with JavaScript unless you reflect it.
Uh, the other thing you might be able to do is like, is there somewhere on this domain where you can get the post data to be read?
And I talked with one of the team in Google and he said on Google, there is one.
So you have scripts.google.com, which is like a script gadget.
There you can have a URL that can receive a post request and you can read the logs.
Wow.
That's, that's basically, but, but they don't have OSDance on their own website.
So Google don't, don't have it for Google.
Uh, I haven't found unexplo, exploitable place.
Uh, that can be used to submit the post request where you can later on read it.
I gotta go reread that.
Cause that section seems so interesting.
Joel, I know that this episode has gone long.
Do you have to bounce right now?
I do have to bounce.
So I don't want to cut this short, but I'm going to let you, I'm going to have to hop on and listen to the rest of this.
You're going to miss the rest of this, uh, you know, a lot of stuff, but yeah, we'll definitely, we'll talk about, about this more.
Um, and you can go back and review it afterwards.
Cause there's going to be some good stuff here.
I can tell already.
So yeah, but yeah, it was awesome talking with you and hopefully you guys have a good rest of your conversation.
Um, yeah, no, that, that sounds nuts.
And I think playing with those different types is, is really something that I haven't played around with too much.
Um, and something that I want to, I want to look into cause the impact of that is, is massive too.
If you are able to leak those in any capacity.
One thing that I was thinking about for the post message thing is like, it's very rare, but if you could find a 307 open redirect as well.
Yeah.
Or you could hit exactly.
They will move it.
It will, it's extremely rare.
Um, but it might be like misconfigurations in there, you know, load balancer kind of things, but it's 307s are hard.
I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm collecting 307s, man.
They're hard to find.
If you could do that or, or, you know, like, well, I guess most of the time.
Yeah.
Cause you couldn't really do it with a, um, with a CRLF either.
You'd really need, yeah, you really need a 307.
Hey, it's, it's tricky, man.
It is.
It's super hard.
That's so, um, the redirect.
So you said sometimes different response types will have different places that they can redirect to that.
Some like, is it, is that accurate?
No, um, I mean that I would say that one is an exception, especially for Google.
Uh, I would say that they are in some sense, you're right, because what happens with the web message or the post message response type or response mode is that then any page on that or because it needs to normalize the origin, right?
So the origin turns into the domain and that means that any page on, on that origin can read the message sent by post message.
So in a sense, yes, the redirect URI will change in that sense because it will just be any, any page on the origin getting that message.
Huh.
I'm not, I'm not fully wrapping my head around that.
Yeah, I don't think so.
But there you also have an attack vector because there's a bunch of post message listeners that works as proxies.
Yeah.
What happens is that when they get a message, they will relay that message to an iframe, for example.
So if you can chain the, the OAuth web, uh, the OAuth web message, posting a message to one of those relays, uh, that just relates it to another iframe.
And then you can find something on that origin of the iframe.
Then you can, uh, then you can also find like, that's another sort of gadgets you could say.
Wow.
Um, but you still need to find something.
Maybe it's a sound like the Reddit bug I had.
I saw that one.
Quite similar.
Yeah.
So the Reddit bug was basically that the, they used the window name to transfer data over to their sandbox.
Uh, and the sandbox had a bunch of XSS.
People knew about it, uh, like long before you could literally run your own, uh, Google analytics on it.
Uh, so if I ran my Google, no Google tag manager.
And if I ran my own Google tag manager, I could run script on the sandbox.
Uh, but, but, but because they named the window, uh, with the payload, uh, the, the payload was transferred down through window name.
And then you can read the fragments through the window name.
Wow dude.
Yeah.
I, I, we mentioned a different one, uh, above sort of similar to that.
Um, there was a report that came out on Pixiv, uh, hacker one program, which is, uh, essentially the vulnerability was the, the app allows you to specify your own Google analytics token.
Yeah.
And if you can do that, then you can leak all sorts of stuff.
And, and with that, you could redirect, um, the OAuth code to that, a page that was using that Google analytics token.
Yes.
Which would allow you to leak the content.
So there's all sorts of ways through stats.
Yeah.
There's all sorts of ways that you can access that.
Um, yeah.
And, and I think this one, this account hijacking by dirty dancing one, I, I it's, it's a very long one.
Like you've mentioned, you know, there's the, you like to do long write-ups, but this is something I'm going to go ahead and reread after this, uh, after this episode again, because there's so many pieces to this where.
Um, yeah.
I mean the, the out of band things there, there, there's so many pieces to this where.
Yeah.
Um, yeah.